In this three part course, you will learn how to
code, deploy, and test three react applications.
Nikolay is the founder of ultimate QA, and
is a popular instructor on software testing.
Consider leaving a comment with any react testing
tips you learned in this course, we're going
to start the first tutorial by creating a very
simple react application using create react app.
Next, we're going to use React testing library
to write a few unit tests. Afterwards, we're
going to learn how to write end to end visual
tests. And then finally, we're going to take
that application and deploy it to Microsoft Azure.
In the second part of the tutorial, we're going to
learn how to create a beautiful birthday reminder
application with some static data. It's going
to be very simple, but we're going to build upon
the skills that we learned in the first tutorial.
Next, we're going to think about a comprehensive
test strategy for this web application. And then
finally, we're going to write those tests and
run them against our birthday reminder webapp.
In the third and final tutorial, that's
actually my favorite one. And I think
you're really going to enjoy it as well, you will
build a beautiful dev portfolio website that you
can use to show off your developer skills. We're
going to code a lot of different components for
this web application. But the tutorial is mostly
going to be focused around a testing strategy,
you will learn a lot of very cool tools like how
POJO, Cypress and jest for component testing and
unit testing. My name is Nikhil Avalon skin, and
I'm a Senior Solutions Architect and I create
tutorials at ultimate QA YouTube channel
on that channel. That's where developers
come to learn how to test and testers come to
learn how to develop. So what are you waiting for,
let's dive right into the tutorials. Alright, so
let's go ahead and start creating our React app,
you can see that I'm here in a folder called react
web up, we've only got a license and a readme.
So let's go ahead and do an NPM
in need to set up this directory.
And so now we have added our package dot
JSON. If you don't already have it installed,
be sure to install create react app, it's a easy
way to create react applications from Facebook.
Once you have create react app installed, you
can actually use create react app to create a new
React application. So let's go ahead and do that.
And we're calling this app my app. Wonderful. So
once that's done downloading and installing, you
can see a bunch of commands that create react app
provides for us to get started and they tell
us exactly what we can do is to CD to my app.
And then in my app, you can see now if we open
this up, we now have a my app folder, has its own
node modules, has a bunch of code here that we
will explore in a moment. So let's actually go
ahead and start up our app and see what that
looks like. And here is the start of our
wonderful little application running on localhost
3000. That's also pointed out in the logs here.
So the really wonderful thing about create react
app is not only does it build us an application
that's ready to go and ready to be modified.
It even comes with a test that we can execute.
If we look at package dot JSON, we can see that
if we run a NPM test command, it's going to run
some tests. And so what we can do is
open up a new tab here and do NPM test.
And that's going to execute a unit test here that
we have an app.test.js. And this test is actually
using React testing library. But what you can
see here is we have a test and that will render
the Learn react link. Here we use a method called
render and we are rendering our app component and
next you can see that we are using the screen to
get an element by text called Learn react. And
then finally we are expecting that link element
to be in the document. This is a just expect
and to be in the document is the React testing
library assertion. That's fantastic, because now
we have a unit test that's already ready for
us. And it can run, regardless of whether our
application is up or not. So if I close down our
app, and then come back here and rerun the tests,
they will still continue to work
because they don't need a server,
we are actually going to go
ahead and push this up into CI.
So the easiest way to get started with GitHub
actions is to come over here to the Actions tab
in your GitHub repo, making sure that you have
one created. And then you can come and say,
a new workflow. GitHub actions will provide you
some suggested workflows, and then it notice it
notices that we are obviously using no J S.
And so then it can recommend us a potential
workflow. And this one right here looks
fantastic. So let's go ahead and click it,
it already comes with a bunch of steps that
have been configured for us. And the other
nice thing about creating your Yamo file here is
that you also get a little IDE that you can use,
for example, you can see that if we don't
do something, right, like, let's say we do
something like this, the UI automatically
highlights anything that may go wrong. And
so it says that we're missing a runs on here.
And so then we can do runs on and then now it
says that the value cannot be null, and
then that's where you supply the value.
So this is what our CI pipeline should look like.
And let's go over it step by step, by the way, you
can see it's automatically gets created in a dot
GitHub slash workflows folder, and then you give
your file a name, I'm calling our CI, pipeline
CI, you can call it of course, anything you want.
And then at the very top, I am setting three
environment variables. These environment variables
are the screener API key sauce, username,
and sauce access key, they are coming from
Secrets variable that is part of GitHub actions,
and then coming from the key called screener API
key here, sauce, username and sauce access
key, so the value from here is retrieved
and stored in the environment variable on the left
hand side. So where are these values coming from?
Let me show you that it's very intuitive
in GitHub actions, you come to Settings.
Scroll down to secrets, you can see I have three
keys that have been created here and inside of
them, they have the corresponding values
that will then be set in here. Okay. Next,
we are saying that we want this CI to run on push
requests and pull requests whenever we do that
to the master branch, main branch. Next, here,
we are defining the jobs that we want to execute,
we're saying we're going to run on Ubuntu
latest, there are multiple types of different
kinds of VMs available for you to execute on.
And I'm going to be running on Node version 14,
you can execute on other node versions if you
want, of course, and then we are using the steps.
A lot of these steps were previously provided
for us. And I've made some modifications
to help you get started faster with your CI
pipeline. So the very first thing we want to do
is install dependencies. And here we are doing
exactly what we were doing in our command line
for our application. And so we would have done
CD my app, right and then done a npm install.
However, I'm simply using an NPM CI, which is
actually faster in GitHub actions because it
ends up caching our dependency. So this is
the recommended action to take in CI. Next,
we're going to build the app, right, this was
just seeding to my app and doing an NPM run build
to make sure we have a production version.
Because whenever we do an npm start here.
And our application comes up here in localhost
3000. And we take a look at our React developer
tools, we can see it's red, and it says this
page is using the development build of React,
which we obviously don't want to use
for production we want to use this year.
We want to use the production build. And
so that's how you do with NPM run build.
Next, we're executing our component tests. After
our app is built, we simply do the same thing
by navigating to that directory and running the
tests exactly as you saw before. And then finally,
we are starting up our application actually
starting the server by doing npm start, and then
we're doing a wait on command that will wait for
the app to start up for up to 60 seconds before
erroring out. And we will expand this pipeline
as we expand our testing. So once it's ready, the
only reason I recommend that you use the UI was
to help you with the IntelliSense. But ultimately,
the best way to do it is to come to my app,
and then make sure we're going to add a GitHub
repo going to do that GitHub slash workflows.
Oops. And then we're going to add a new file here.
If you're enjoying this tutorial
and want to support this channel,
be sure to hit the thumbs up button for the
video. And if you want to be notified of
every time a new tutorial is released, hit the
subscribe button. Let's call it CI dot Tamil.
It will look exactly as I showed
you here, I actually named the
two CI two so that we can see, let's
quit our tests and do a and do a push.
And once we do a push, that should start executing
our CI pipeline. Let's come and take a look at
that. We'll see that I have this new branch open.
So let's go ahead and do a PR with this branch.
I made one mistake here, I should have
put GitHub workflows in the very root,
not inside of my app. So what you'll see is I
moved that to the correct location did another
push. And so now we have a CI pipeline
that started executing here's the name
called CI to exactly the name
that we gave it in the Yamo file.
And it did fail after nine seconds. So let's go
ahead and take a look at exactly what happened.
So the error says that we can only install
packages with a package lock JSON, or NPM,
shrimp crab JSON. So let's go ahead and fix
that. In order to do that, what we need to do is
come to my app and do an npm install.
Which will create a package lock dot
JSON. And then let's go ahead and add it.
And we can watch our c ci rerun. Here you
can see we just committed 14 seconds ago,
here's a little yellow circle that shows that our
CI pipeline is running. Let's go ahead and take
a look at the details. Wonderful, so there is our
CI pipeline that is not only able to build our app
and start it up, it's also able to even
run some component tests against it.
So if we take a look of where we are in our
testing journey, you can see based on this
table that we've actually got a pretty long
way to go before our app is fully tested.
It's a really tiny app that we haven't even made
any functional changes to. And so far, the only
thing that we know about this application without
testing it manually is that a URL with the correct
text does exist in the DOM of the application.
We've validated that with a component test,
which came with our app create react app. And
we did that using React testing library in jest.
How about actually knowing whether the URL is
correct, right? It may be there with the right
tags but doesn't go to the right location. So
let's go ahead and write up another test for that.
The very first thing that we
want to do is make sure that we
are running our test suites here in and
then we can add a test that looks like this,
where we say where we're testing that a URL is
correct rendering our component is before getting
our link element as before. However, now we
are going to validate that the href of the link
element will contain ultimate qa.com, because
that's where we want our URL to navigate to.
And then once we hit save, watch this window in
the bottom right. It's going to execute all of the
tests in this file. Here, the first one passed,
which makes sense, but the second one failed,
the URL is correct. It's saying that we expected
ultimate qa.com. But we got react J s.org. And
that's because we need to make an update to
our application to go to ultimate qa.com.
So let's come here and go to app Jas. And
we will change the URL to ultimate qa.com.
We're going to hit save, our tests are going
to rerun, and now both of them have succeeded.
Also, while we're here, we this link text is no
longer correct, because we're not going to learn
react, instead, we are going to learn testing.
So let's put let's learn testing, and the above
and hit Save now. And our tests both have failed.
And the reason that they both have failed is we
can take a look at our logs. And it seemed that
it's unable to find an element with the text,
learn react. And then it spits out the
DOM for us here showing everything that
is visible. And of course, this is the text that
exists. However, the this exercise also showed us
that having text as a check in our test is
not really a good strategy because we can
often change the text of our links. And
so we can instead use a better strategy
such as supplying a data dash attribute.
And so here we can do a data dash Test ID.
And we can call it a learn link. We'll hit
save here, we'll come back to app dot test.
And now instead of getting by text, we
can get by ID. So let's go and do that.
Let's give this a run.
And now everything passes because we are getting
our element by Test ID. And of course,
if we decide to change the text
our tests continue to work. Let's go
ahead and push this up into our CI.
Here's our commit. And here is our check.
We can check on it back in a moment.
So our CI pipeline has executed successfully,
which is wonderful. So let's see where we
are in our testing journey. So
at this point, we are we have now
tested that the URL is correct. Now how about
making sure that our application actually renders
correctly that we can do a this test as well as
making sure that our application looks correct on
web and mobile using two different technologies.
We're going to use WebDriver. Io and shift right
by testing our rendered application later
in the stage of the development cycle. And
we're going to use visual snapshots to check
our application in different resolutions
in the browser to make sure that our app is
responsive and that it looks correct on different
types of devices. And for that we are going to
use WebDriver IO lessons. All WebDriver IO let's
configure WebDriver IO,
you're gonna get a nice handy menu that allows
it allows you to decide what you're going to do.
So we're going to execute in the cloud using
Sauce Labs. Yes, this will be our username,
and this will be our access key. No, we
don't want to do that which is the default.
Once you've selected all the options,
now you're going to wait for WebDriver IO
to install all the appropriate packages.
So once all the installation is done, the
only other thing that you'll need to install
is the WD IO sync service. And so once you
have everything installed, this is what our
package json looks like everything
that we added. If we look at the diff,
you can see we've got a few WD i o
services added for our testing purposes.
WebDriver. Io tests by default, go to test
specs directory, and in here I created a
visual.spec.js file. And in here, we
are going to have our visual test.
This visual test uses a standard describe it
format. And then the commands come from the
browser object which is a global object
from webdriverio. We navigate to a URL,
and then we execute two important commands.
First, we do it, which will provide a name
for the app that we're testing. So we can
say, my react app, for example. And then
the next one we're going to do is a snapshot.
This is capturing a snapshot of the page that
we want to test. And so in this case, it's our
homepage. And so we are calling it home page.
So the config file for WebDriver. Io lives
over here. And there's a lot going on in
here. But that we can take a look at only the
important components. So here I've created
two constants called visual options and sauce
options where I am setting some API keys. Here,
I'm setting the screener API key, I am providing
a project name, I'll show you how that correlates
to the actual UI. And then I'm saying to scroll
and stitch screenshots to enable that to true
so that when my apps are pulled up, the
entire page is scrolled and stitched together.
Next, I am enabling a sauce Connect, which is an
HTTPS proxy that allows me a secure connection
from a local host into the cloud execution
environments for screener and Sauce Labs.
This is telling us where the specs are for our
tests. And then finally, the most important part
of this, I would say, is the configuration to
run on multiple different browsers and operating
systems. So I'm running this on two of the most
popular browser resolutions. The very first one is
this one here, on this viewport size, which
is the most popular desktop and running on
Windows, 10, and Chrome, and then the other type
of browser that we're running on is MacOS Safari
on this resolution, which is an iPhone X viewport
size. And of course, we can have a lot more
resolutions here. And what's going to happen is,
our visual spec is going to run on both of these
platforms at the same time. We can of course run
it. We can run our tests using this command here.
But instead let's add a test script to our
package json. We can come here and add.
And then ensuring that in a separate
terminal, you have the application
actually running on localhost 3000,
because it has to be up for us to do
end to end visual testing, we can
now run our visual testing command.
At this point, we can see that it's executing two
specs. And of course, that's our Safari and Chrome
specs. Let's go take a look at the screener
UI to see what's going on over there. So we
can see that Here is our new app dash two that
we started. There are currently tests running.
The build has failed. And the reason why
it failed is because we have two brand new
snapshots that we've never accepted before.
What screeners currently telling us is that,
hey, I've got these two snapshots of these
resolutions of this page here of the homepage.
And I don't know whether they are
acceptable to you or not. So we can open
each one up and take a look. Does this
look good to Austin? Correct? Yes, it does,
we can come here and set this as a baseline.
From this point forward, every single automated
test will validate against this version of the
baseline. And this was the bigger resolution here.
And this one looks fantastic to us as
well. Let's go ahead and accept it.
And so now from this point forward, and new
executions will run against this baselines. Let's
also now add this visual step to our CI pipeline
and see that execute. Here we are back in our CI
Yamo. We've added a brand new step our after after
application has rendered to run Visual tests and
performing the following commands. Let's go ahead
and check all this into Ci and see what happens.
We've got a new command here for adding visual
test. And here is our CI pipeline executing.
So here's our pipeline after execution, we can
see our visual tests have executed successfully
with a checkmark. And if we scroll all the way
down, we can see that two tests have passed.
So the current version of our application, it's
a little boring, right, let's make it a little
bit better, and actually see the power of visual
testing. So we're going to replace this logo with
another logo by coming into app dot j s. And we
can see that up here at the top, we're pointing
to an SVG, let's change this SVG. And instead,
we're going to point to me dot jpg, which is a
nice file that I've uploaded. So let's save that
and watch her application ran there. And here is
the cutest little dog in the world. Her name
is Mia. And of course, we can also even change
this link right here to his channel B,
instead of learn testing, we can change it to
something else, we can say, learn
testing, with Nikolai, and Mia.
Fantastic, our application rebuilt. And this is
what it looks like. And we can even run our tests
to make sure that everything is
working as before our component tests,
both of them working successfully, because
remember, we added that nice Beta Test ID
attribute. And now we can check in these
changes and see what happens to our visual test.
Here's our change in GitHub. Let's see what's
going on. So now if we look at the screener UI,
we can see that our new app two has two changes,
let's click Take a look and see exactly what
happened. And so what screener shows is two visual
changes that have occurred as screener users a
smart hybrid div meeting, meaning that it analyzes
the DOM and element shifts, and identifies exactly
the two elements that we have changed. And so now
as far as to decide whether this is a valid change
or not. And yes, this is a valid change. And it
looks fantastic. And we want to use this as the
new version of the baseline. So we're going to
accept this one. Looking at this page here. We
like all of the changes here as well. And we can
accept that as well. And with all that said, we
are pretty far down in our coding and the testing
journey. We validated pretty much everything about
our application. We validated that the app renders
correctly and that the app looks as expected
on the web and mobile using our
visual DOM to database tests,
also known as Antwuan test, and we did
it with the following technologies.
So how awesome would it be if we can actually
deploy this application and then test it in a
real production environment? Well, we can actually
do that using Microsoft Azure. And we are going to
use their Azure static web apps feature, their
Azure static web apps feature is basically a
simple way to deploy applications without
having to worry about infrastructure and regions
and a bunch of other stuff. As you'll see,
it's a very easy way to make this possible. So
we're gonna go ahead and do that, in order to
do this, you're gonna need an Azure account,
you can get your Azure account by going to
azure.microsoft.com. And it's absolutely free,
you can sign up for free, and then you can
follow along in the tutorial. Next, you're
going to need to install an Azure static web apps
extension. So here in your Visual Studio code,
you're going to come to extensions, and install
Azure static web apps extension. Once you have
add your static web apps, you will have this
little icon Azure, you will come in there, you
will come into static web apps, and you will click
the plus symbol to add a new Azure static web app.
So here is asking for us to provide a name a
unique name for our web app, let's call it my
react web app. Nexus, it asked me to select the
configuration, we obviously have a React project.
Next, it's asking where is the source code of
our application, and ours is not at the root,
but it's inside of my app. That's where all
the code goes. And then finally, tasking,
where will your application get built to.
So when we come here, and run NPM build,
that's the final production version
of the application that goes here into
the build folder. And so this here is correct.
And that's what we're going to supply.
Inside of our GitHub project, we see that
we have a new action that was added. And
it's called Azure static web apps workflow. And
basically, Microsoft Azure added a new Yamo file,
that it's calling right here, Azure static web
apps, blah, blah, blah. And so then this has a
configuration for building and deploying our
application. And so once we open it up, we
can take a look at everything that happened here,
the longest and most important step was actually
building and deploying our project. If we open it
up, we'll see a bunch of stuff that was executed.
But ultimately, the most important part was this
at the end here, where our web app was actually
deployed to this URL, which was dynamically
generated for us. And if we click on this URL, we
will see that here is our beautiful and wonderful
application alive in production. I did have to add
one other thing here, when I checked into the
code is there was a settings dot JSON that came
along. Let's see if I can find that here.
That came along. And so what was very,
I needed to push that up into my pull request
as well. And that settings that JSON just has
these three things configured as well. And then
once I push that up the bill to work successfully,
we can also talk about that file here that was
added for us. It has a lot of stuff going on,
which is not really anything important. What
the most important part here is basically that
these three parameters talking about where our app
is located and where the build output is created.
And so in this instance, it basically just builds
and deploys our job. I didn't set up any of this,
it was done for me automatically, which
is really fantastic. And then here at the
end is just a close pull request the job which
basically once a pull request is closed. It'll
basically close out the job for us. So
that's really all that was added here for us
all automatically using using Azure static web
apps. Now, how do we actually write the tests
for our production environment,
let's go ahead and do that.
So the very first thing that I want to do here is
actually update our app. So if you run npm start
this this was an okay picture, it can definitely
be better. And so let's make it better in our app.
So what we're going to do here is come to my app
in the source, we will change the picture
to a better one. So here we have Mia I'm
going to read name this one to me old. And
rename this one to meow, you can see this
one is much better of my cute little dog
being violently attacked by her boyfriend.
Fantastic. So obviously, that's going to now load
up in our app. So there it is a much better image.
And so then with that change done, we also need to
update our Azure pipeline for being able to handle
all over the testing. And so to do that,
we simply do everything that I did in this
file. And so it's basically a merge of the Azure
file that we had before that was automatically
created for us by Azure static web apps,
and the CI file that we have before. And so
all of this you've seen before setting environment
variables, all of this configured here, however,
now, we have a built in Deploy Job, I kept a bunch
of the logic that was there from Microsoft Azure.
And then we did all of our local testing here. So
installing dependencies, building the app, running
component tests, starting the app, running visual
tests on localhost, this is a new step we were
doing it before, but I just simply renamed it,
calling it our run Visual tests on a local host.
And you can see we are running NPM, run
test visual, which if we look at that, here
you can see NPM run does points to this config
here. And then we're also going to have test
visual prod, which is going to run the same config
is going to have a debug higher log level. And
it's also going to point at a base URL. So let's
continue here in our Azure, Azure Yamo. So here is
the build and deploy step that we got from the
Azure static web apps, I literally just copied
and pasted this in here, everything all the same.
And then the only part that I needed to add was
adding visual tests to be executed on prod. And
so that's that script that we were using before,
however, we need to point to a different URL, and
which URL are we going to use? Well, this one,
now that we know our production URL, we can use it
for testing production purposes. So let's go back
to here. And we're going to go to our package
json. And we're going to update our script.
So we're going to change our base URL to this
right here. And so if we're using WebDriver IO,
so that's how we're able to pass on this parameter
here. And we're setting it to our production URL.
And then this close pull request job remains
just as before. And so now, let's go ahead and
give this a run. Let's stop
this, let's see our changes.
And don't forget that I renamed our job to Azure
CI. And let's push this up. If we come back here
to pull requests, we see that we have some checks
being executed. Let's take a look at those.
So here we have our Azure CI pipeline that we
just created by updating the Yamo file. Let's
click on the details. And now we are going to see
all of the steps. And let's watch them execute,
and then see the final outcome. Oh, something
happened to our CI pipeline looks like visual
tests failed on localhost. Do you know why that
is? We're going to figure that out in a moment.
So the reason that our tests failed
on localhost is because remember,
we made the change to the image. And so now if
we come back here to screener, we see that two
have changed. If we look at the changes, we
obviously see that the image has changed. So
this is good for us. We don't need to worry
about it. It's absolutely the new version that
we want in our application. We're going
to accept everything that was selected.
And then we are simply going to rerun this job
and now everything should pass successfully.
Wonderful our build has finished successfully.
So let's go ahead and actually take a look at
every thing that that's happened. Here was
just some actions that we've already seen.
We've seen installing of dependencies building
the app, running Component Tests starting the app.
And then here is the visual tests on localhost.
Those have succeeded, because we finally accepted
a new baseline. Right, we can see that one has
passed on Chrome and windows and the other one
on macOS. Next, we have the build and deploy task
here that was using the Azure static web apps,
action. And that all succeeded successfully.
If we scroll down, we'll be able to see the
URL to which it was displayed to. And then
finally, we run our visual tests on production,
which is pretty much the same thing. Except
we are just running a different script,
write a test of visual prod. And you can see the
WebDriver i o configuration that was enabled here
pointing at that URL to which we published
and the tests there passed successfully.
And that's pretty much it, we've successfully
created a CI pipeline that not only tests
our application, but then deploys it to
production and retests, you can now go ahead
and make $100 million on this application.
So just to summarize, in this tutorial,
we created a very simple react web application
using create react app. We then created component
tests using React testing library. Afterwards, we
shifted right, by creating automated visual tests,
using screener and WebDriver. We added the
code to a CI pipeline using GitHub actions.
And then finally, they use Azure static
web apps to easily release all of that
code into the Microsoft Azure Cloud. So that's our
application lives in the production environment.
And we can test it. My name is Nikolai Bulacan,
you can learn more about me at ultimate qa.com.
And it's been a true pleasure being able to show
you all of the skills to have a wonderful day.
Hey, and welcome to building a birthday reminder
application with React js. In this tutorial, we're
going to code a React application from scratch.
Next, we're going to consider a wonderful testing
strategy for application. And finally, we're going
to implement a single test that's going to provide
us a ton of coverage on our web application. My
name is Nikolai adelakun. And on this channel,
I help as that all over the world build, test
and deploy applications in a continuous manner.
If you want more amazing content like this,
be sure to smash the thumbs up button, so that
I continue creating content for you. So grab your
computer, grab your coffee, and let's do this.
Alright, so you ready to get started,
let me put on my magical coding glasses.
And let's begin. So the code base that we are
going to be working on is going to be coming from
this project right here. You can see it's a fork
of this other project that has a bunch of React
web apps. And we're building on top of those
by teaching about how to test and deploy them.
We're going to be working on this birthday
reminder, there are two folders here,
there's a setup folder. And there is a final
folder. The final folder is basically what the
code is going to look like at the end. And the
setup folder is what you're going to be working
from. It's a blank folder to get you started.
And it's going to have some boilerplate code in
there. And then we are going to code out the rest.
So let me show you exactly what that looks like.
So of course, first step, you're gonna get clone.
You can if you want, you can fork my project,
and then do a git clone. And once you have that
down, you'll navigate to the final directory.
So I'm just going to do that and then
I'm going to do an npm install and start
so that we can see what the final version
of the application will look like.
Alright, so there it is, you can see
our application is running, of course,
and localhost 3000. And this is what it looks
like. It shows the birthday. So we have today,
the people whose birthday it is. And if you
press the Clear All button, it clears all of
the birthdays. That's really about it, the app is
super simple. However, we have to get started with
somewhere simple and build up. And along the way,
we're going to figure out not only how to code it,
but also how to test it. So now that we
know what the application looks like,
let's go ahead and implement it together. And
then afterwards, we're going to talk about the
testing strategy. So I'm gonna cue this over
here, and you're gonna follow along with me.
So you're gonna navigate one route
off, you're going to navigate into
setup. And that's where we're going to be working
from also, I am going to change to a new branch.
We're going to work from birthday tutorial. And if
you want to follow my commands, you'll see those
in that branch. So obviously, we have the source
folder. If you're in setup, you'll also need to do
an npm install. While that installs, we can talk
about in app J S, you can see there's nothing here
except this h2 that says reminder project set
up in this data dot j s, you'll see it's just
an array of metadata about each one of our users,
just again, keeping it simple, not needing to pull
it from anywhere right now. Our index, CSS already
has all the styling, right, we don't want to spend
hours, putting together all the styling for our
application. So it's already here and ready for
you, all we have to do is implement and I'd rather
spend more time actually implementing projects and
less time worrying about CSS in index.js. This
is our entry point for our application. And then
our list.js will contain the list of users. And
we're going to iterate over them. And you'll see
exactly what we do in here. But in the meantime,
everything should have installed and if you do npm
start, it'll pull up our app. And I am actually
going to pull this out we'll put this side by
side with our editor. So it makes life easier.
And we'll put this over here just like that.
So you can see what this is showing right now.
It's just a our app J S. It's just a simple pink
background with a header that says reminder,
Project Setup. Let's go ahead and start coding.
Alright, so let's start doing some work on this
application. We're going to start working out
of app J S. Let me go ahead and close the window
on the right just so you can see more space here.
And we'll close this down here as well. So with
that, we are going to get rid of this. And we will
return a much larger block of code. And
now we are going to add a main element and
why it's main. If we come into
our index CSS, we will see that
the styling for the main component is over
here. That's going to be the wrapper for our
main portion of the application. And
inside of that, we're going to have a
section and this section is going to get a class
name. And that's going to be called container.
So as soon as I save, you can see exactly what
this looks like. Again, if we look at the index,
find container, you can see that CSS styling
for the container is right there. Inside of this
section, which is the white part right?
What are we going to have in there? Well,
we're going to have an h3 and that's
going to display the amount of birthdays
So far, we're just going to do everything
static and then make things a bit more dynamic.
So we'll do something like this, save
it, boom, see that come up right there.
Next, we're going to import our list components.
So you can see the import is already on top on
line number three. And that is going to
be dynamically generated once we put the
logic in there. So for now, that's all that
looks like because if you look at lists,
you can see that this is all it has for
now. Next, we are going to add a button.
So button, and then we're going to do an on click
method, right? What is it going to do on a click?
So what is it going to do on click for now, again,
always keeping it simple, let's zoo an anonymous
function. And that's not going to do anything. And
instead, it's simply going to do a console log.
Just like that. And let's
give this button a title.
And save that, and boom, there is our button.
And if we come here and inspect, scroll down.
Go over to the console, and click it, you can see
that it says clicked because that was the method
that we coded. By the way if you're wondering how
I quickly created an anonymous function, that was
keyboard shortcut, a NFN. So you can type
this a and a fan. And you can see it's an
anonymous function. And then when I hit
tab, I get this automatically generated.
And that comes from there it is this
extension right there. Beautiful. So
App J S so far is up and running. Now let's
go ahead and fill it with the actual users.
All right, so next step, we're going to work
out of our list component. Our list component
is going to contain all of the birthdays that
are coming from data Jas, right. So you can see
it contains the name, the age, the image,
and an ID. And this list is just going to
basically iterate over all of that and list those
components. So with that said, let's get rid
of this heading. And instead, we're going
to keep the fragment here, we are going to
do a map. And actually, what we'll want to do is
inside of this list, we're going to pass in an
object that we're going to call people, okay,
using this object, we are then going to do a map.
And inside of there, we're going
to do another anonymous function.
And then we're going to map over a person.
And for every single person, we can D structure
that object have a deconstructed object,
and this is going to take in each of the
properties of our person. So we got that D
There you go. Next, we're going to want to return
the component. That's going to be an article
and inside of that article, we are going
to have an image we're gonna have a source
of image. You can see automatically
how those destructured properties are
coming back here to give it an alt it's
gonna have have the name of the person.
Beautiful. And then below, and
then we're going to add a div.
And that div is going to have an h for. And
that's going to be the name of the person.
And then we're going to have a paragraph. And
then that's going to say that age and years.
Just like that. And then up here in the article,
we definitely want to have a key for the map,
so that's going to be the ID. And then we want
to give it some styling, which is going to be
person. So again, if we look at index dot css, and
we look for look for person, there is that styling
for the person. Let's go back, let's save
it and see exactly what that looks like.
Oh, it failed. Let's see what's wrong here.
And I think the reason for that is we haven't
passed in any object to our list component.
And so that's why it's undefined. And so
now if we come back here, we can actually define
it. So the very first thing we're going to need
is a D structured array. So let's do
that. And that's going to be people
set the people. And that's going to do use state.
And it's going to take in the data that we are
getting from here. There you go. And then using
this information, what we're going to want to do
is obviously update this one to a dynamic value.
So that'll just be people dot length. So now we'll
show that dynamically. And then our list, we're
actually going to want to pass in the value of
people. And that's going to be people. Beautiful.
And I think that's correct. Let's give this
a run a save, boom, there it is, there is our
application, you can see exactly how it looks,
and how each of the components came into play
from the list. So we've got everything wrapped
in an article, each one of these is an article.
Inside of that we have an image, and then we have
the person's name, and then the age and years,
all that's left is to actually make the button
work, which currently is just console logging.
While and making that happen is extremely easy.
And it only takes a single method. So that's just
setting the people. And inside of that, we are
just going to pass an empty array, which is going
to clear everything right. So if we save that,
and now we should be able to click this button.
And you can see that now it says your birthdays
today, obviously the counter being updated
from this, the list of people values being
passed in from here into here. And then the
onclick is using the Set people method
from above, passing in an empty array.
Our application is done now,
how do we actually test it?
So we now have our web application is
there and ready. And the question is,
well, how are we actually going to test
it? What is the most optimal strategy,
our web application contains multiple components
that need to be tested. There is, for example,
the dynamic birthday counter that we coded in
the logic for that obviously needs to be correct.
There's the clear all functionality of the button
that needs to ensure that the list is clear.
And then probably the most important part is the
look and feel of the entire application on web.
And obviously mobile is also important. So how are
we going to test our application to ensure that
everything is functioning as expected, so let's
start working through the testing period. Amid
and see which approach makes sense. We're gonna
start at the very bottom, the unit test layer.
Unit tests are really great for low level types of
tests, right? If you're having like, functions to
add integers, for example, or a function that
performs some parsing of some data, those types
of tests are really good for unit tests. And
honestly, for most react web applications,
unit testing is rarely ever necessary, unless you
have some deep JavaScript logic that you need to
test. So unit testing are not going to apply here
because it's, we're going to need too many unit
tests. And also, they're not the right use case
here. What's likely better and more applicable for
web applications, especially in React are
components has components has are a level higher,
they ensure that the look and functionality work
together that the component that we created, such
as the list component is functioning correctly
tied to all of the backend code. So if we had
component tests, we could have a component
test for a list. And then that would ensure
that when we pull in the data from the data
that Jas that is being correctly pulled in
and displaying the correct counter, we could
also have a component test for the button
and ensure that when we do the onClick method,
that the button performs the correct operation.
But what about the look and feel of the
application? How do we check that that is
working? And looking correctly, we could
definitely move up another level into end
to end tests, right? And to answer is make sure
that everything from the DOM to the base database
is behaving correctly. We can Yeah, click a
button using a Antwan test and ensure that
when the button is clicked, it's actually
clearing all of the functionality. However,
still, how do we ensure the visual correctness
of the application? And what if I told you that
there was a really cool strategy that we can use
is going to be two validation points in a single
test, and we can ensure 100% Working functionality
of our application? Let's go and make it happen.
All right. So we actually no longer need to show
the application here. So we're just going to go
ahead and stop it so that we have full screen.
And the technologies that we are going to use
for our testing is WebDriver. I O and screener.
So we're actually going to perform a visual
end to end test that's going to allow
us to render the entire application,
make sure that it looks correctly. And then
we're going to clear the entire list and make
sure that that looks correctly. And with those
two validation points, opening the application,
make sure it's in the right state, clearing the
button, make sure that it's in the right state,
we'll ensure 100% coverage of our application
not and leave us knowing super comfortable that
nothing is wrong with our app. So let's go
ahead and get started installing the code.
So we're gonna do NP X, WD, I, O, and O. And
let me make sure I'm in the right directory
for so let's CD to one. And then we're
going to CD to set up. And then we'll do MPX
WebDriver i o like that, and
then it'll take us through
a super user friendly installation process.
It'll let us pick a bunch of dependencies.
While it installs, I'll tell you a little
bit about WebDriver. Io WebDriver. Io is,
as it says here next gen browser and mobile
automation test framework for No, Jas. It's really
good for end to end testing with browser and
mobile. So if you're looking for a solution that
can tackle web and mobile at the same time, plus
it has other capabilities like being able to plug
in with visual end to end testing tools such as
screener WebDriver. Io is the right tool for you.
So next, we're gonna answer a few of these
questions. Where's the automation backend located?
We are going to be used running in the cloud using
Sauce Labs because Sauce Labs is integrated into
screen and we're going to need Sauce Labs. I
have an account if you don't have Then go ahead
and sign up at sauce labs.com. Grab your free
account there. And I'll show you how to set up
that. So it's already asking me about the
environment variables for my username and access
key for Sauce Labs. And yes, mine are saved in
sauce username and access key in my bash profile
just like that. No, we don't want to run headless
tests. In which region we're going to do us
which framework Mocha is fine. There's also
Jasmine and cucumber options. Now we don't have
a compiler, our specs located that your default
on just hitting Enter for most of these. Yeah,
let's have WebDriver IO generate some test files
for us, just so we can look at exactly what those
look like page objects. No, thank you. That's
way overkill. For our testing purposes here, spec
reporter is totally good. And then the services
that we're going to install sauce service,
we don't need the chrome driver service chrome
driver services for running tests locally
unnecessary for our purposes, because we're only
going to be using a single visual end to end test
to tackle all of our problems. And then
I'm going to hit enter here base URL
and install I don't know what
it is about typing on camera.
You guys make me nervous. Whenever I have
to type on camera, I forget how to type.
Okay, beautiful. So it says successfully setup
our project. Alright, in birthday reminder setup,
let me just show you a few of the things that
were added. Package dot JSON was obviously updated
with WebDriver I O. We also got the config
for WebDriver I O. And we got an example test.
Here, let's actually open that up so that we can
see what that looks like. It's a very simple test,
navigate to this URL, and then looks like it
logs in. Let's actually give it a run using npm.
Run WD IO. And we'll see exactly what that
looks like. So there it is starting up.
Pull up Sauce Labs here.
Alright, so we see that a minute ago, I had just
executed called my login application. And we can
open it up. And the coolest part is just running
the video and seeing exactly what happened.
So there it is, there is our functional end to
end test. So we know our environment is set up,
the next step we actually
need to do is set up screener
so that we can do visual end to end testing
instead of functional end to end testing.
So let's talk about the configuration for
WebDriver I O and how to integrate it with
screener. So at the very top, I've set up a
visual options object. And that's taking in an
API key and a project name, the API keys
coming from screener I'll show you in a moment.
And the project name basically just corresponds
to the project that we're working on. And I
named that birthday reminder, we also have source
options here as well. And those are also taking
in a username and access key. You can see all I
have three environment variables here. If you want
to get your environment variables in account,
User Settings, you'll find your username and
access key for sauce and screener, which is our
visual end to end testing tool. Once you login
and then you go to your account and click my API
key. You'll get that API key as well save them
all to your bash profile. And now we can easily do
CI CD and testing on our machines. A bunch of this
was already here. I just cleaned it up
some more. You can actually even see in my
diff. What I've changed, just cleaned it up made
it less verbose. There's a bunch of descriptions
that were in the WebDriver IO config to
show you everything that was going on.
But the most important components are
this service portion that I added.
This allows us to create a secure
connection from the screen or cloud to
to our local machine, right, our application is
running in local host. And so they need to be able
to talk to each other to perform the appropriate
validations. So I enabled that service here,
I added these capabilities to be able to
point to the screen or hub. And finally,
I have an array here that will allow me to run
across as many browsers and operating systems as
I want. Currently, I have it sets to desktop with
this one is the most popular desktop resolution
currently. And so I set it to that resolution,
set it to run on Chrome, Windows 10, and latest,
and then passing that viewport size, we can add
more of these capabilities to run across more
browsers and operating systems. And of course,
we can also change this part off if we want.
So that's the configuration, what does the test
actually look like? Let's come back to the test
that have shown me let me show you that here.
Here's what the test actually looks like. It's
used as a standard describe it format, I'm saying
describe my birthday reminder app that it should
look correctly. Next, we're navigating to a URL
URL here, I'm not specifying anything, because
the base URL is set in WebDriver. Io config.
Let me show you where that's that's down here.
Next, we're having an init command. By the way,
all of this documentation is available here in
Doc's, visual, and to Doc's, you can follow along
there, it'll help you get set up. But of course,
I'm here to explain as well, this will just
basically start the execution for the test.
And then this is one of the most important
pieces is capturing the snapshot. So here I am,
capturing a snapshot and calling it the
default state because it says initially
when our application opens. Next, after it opens,
I am going to click on our button. What I've done
here to is add a data Test ID attribute to make
our button more unique. And so in order for this
to be possible, we have to come back to app J
S. And in our button, we're going to add a data
Test ID attribute, calling it clear. So now our
button has this unique Test ID that we can use for
identification purposes. And we're going to click
it. So now that obviously clears our application,
and then we're going to capture another snapshot
of the app. And then we are going to end our test
and ensure that there were no messages coming
back in our results object. Let's give this a
run. And I think you'll understand exactly what's
happening. Let me pull up the terminal here. So we
are just going to be we're just going to do NPM,
run WD IO is going to start up here. If I didn't
break anything, it's going to start running. I
think it's already running, but give it a moment.
All right, there it is, it's executing. Let's
come back to screener. And what we'll see here
is a our birthday reminder, we're going
to see that currently there is a session
being executed. It's running on this resolution.
Here's some information about it. And in a moment,
I'll show you what comes out of this. I made
a quick error, there should be two new states.
Let me show you what happened it see
how here it can't click on element
data Test ID because it wasn't found.
What I did was I actually modified
the wrong app J S. So we're going to grab
this and put it in the right app J S in the
setup folder here. There you go. And now we're
going to add that button, which is exactly what's
running, save that now rerun these tests. And
we'll be back in a moment. All right, there it is.
Two new states just came in for our application.
What does that actually mean? Well, let's open it
up and see what happened. Look, here, you'll see
that on this resolution, Chrome 95, Windows 10.
I have my birthday reminder app, this birthday
reminder app has a default state. If we open
it up, we see our birthday reminder app here.
How does it look? It looks absolutely perfect.
We have the correct amount of birthdays. We
have all the right people and all the styling
is absolutely correct. That is the best and most
powerful thing about visual end to end testing is
that we can capture the state and the look of the
entire application in a case single command. And
so that's exactly what we did here. And so we
validated anything that we could have possibly
needed to validate in this default state, right.
And so this looks good, we are going to accept
this, this will be used as a future iteration of
our new code. And then the next stage is the only
other possible state of our application, which
is the clear state. And so you remember, I press
the Clear All button. And this looks absolutely
correct here as well. So not only do we know that
the Clear All button functions correctly, which we
could have done with a number of types of tests,
this test also ensures that our application
looks good as well. All of this logic here
is correct. And so we can accept this as well. And
now what this means is that any future iteration
of our tests against our application will
validate against these baselines and check hey,
does this look correct? Or has something changed?
In fact, if we wanted to make a change, let's say
we went into data, J, s, and doesn't matter,
let's remove our very first element. Save that,
of course, now, we're not going to
have five. And we wanted, we can
run our tests. Actually, let's
look at our application first. And,
look, it only has four people now.
Right. And so if we rerun our tests,
let me show you exactly what this will tell us.
Think about it. If we read running our
tests, and it's comparing to the baseline,
which functionality has changed and which
functionality remains the same? Well,
the clear all remains exactly the same. So that
test is going to pass. And then the default state
that part has broken. And we know we've broken it.
So I will see that individual tests in a moment.
There it is, check it out. Exactly. As I
mentioned, one changed one accepted rule. Let's
review what's changed. See that? Look, it's
identifying exactly what happened. One element
removed. And this, of course, has changed the
text. And so now we determine is this correct
the correct state of our application? Or did we
introduce a bug in this case, we introduced the
bug. This was rejected. And now we need to go
and fix our application and ensuring that it's
looking and functioning correctly.
So thanks so much for joining me
for this tutorial. I hope you enjoyed building
and testing a birthday reminder application.
I've been Nikolai as of Alaskan. So if you enjoyed
this content, and you want to see me build that
application, go ahead and smash that thumbs up
button. And if you want to be notified of future
video tutorials, hit the subscribe button. And
finally, if you want to learn something specific
around react, building applications and testing
them, comment down below and I'll be sure to bring
those tutorials to your YouTube feed. Thanks
again. Have an amazing day. See you next time.
Today, we're going to build a
beautiful next J S personal portfolio
website. This is what it looks like if you
navigate to Nikolai dot tech, you'll be able
to see a live version of the application.
You can see how beautiful it looks.
Everything here is functional. These icons
will take you to different resources that you
want people to know about yourself. And if you
scroll down, you will see a collection of all
of the projects that you've done. You can put here
your testing projects, your development projects,
anything you've done with the community. At the
very bottom, you'll see the technologies that
you are familiar with and show that off to your
potential employers. There is a little section to
describe yourself and who you are, and even
show a timeline of your experience and your
accomplishments. And at the very bottom we'll see
a personal accomplishment section that describes
some of the things that you've been able to do in
your awesome career. There's even a link that you
can click and someone will be able to email you
of course also importantly is this website is
absolutely Totally responsive. So mobile first
world, it's absolutely unacceptable in today's
world to have a website that is not responsive,
and you can see how our mobile view looks,
everything looks wonderful, it's easy to read,
easy to see, you can interact with everything.
If you want to view an application, you can click
on the application, and then it'll take you there.
Alright, so with all that said, let's jump
into building testing this application.
So let's go ahead and actually grab the code.
So you'll be able to locate the code at this
repository. And while you're there, please give
the repository a star. And then you will be able
to get the final version of the portfolio here
in this dev portfolio folder. This is where
all the code lives. So if you pull this down
and start the server, you'll be able to see a
live version of the application. And I even
created a starter version of the code for
us. So if you come to the branches, and
search for dev, portfolio, start branch
net, and then you can download this code, come
to code and download zip, you'll be able to
get a starter version of the application. If
you come in here, you'll see it's bare bones,
it's not fully finished. But it's a wonderful
place for us to start and avoid a lot of the
unnecessary boilerplate setup. When you download
that branch, you can start your own project,
of course. And once you start that project,
just pulling all of the folders into your
new project. And this is exactly what it's going
to look like. In fact, what you can actually do
is you can first do an npm install. And then
after you do an NPM, install NPM run Dev.
And what you'll see is, it's actually going to
start up our application on localhost 3000. So
let's pull that up here. And this right here is
our starter application, what you can see is it
just has bare bones styling, and it has all of the
components that we are going to code out together.
So the header, the hero, so on and so forth.
You can see in our package json, we have all of
dependencies that we are going to use throughout
the tutorial already set up. And then if we take
a look at the source code, you'll see that the
bare bones components have been written. So for
example, here's what an accomplishments component
looks like. Already, you can see all it says
All it has is a Dave that says accomplishments.
And of course that corresponds to that component,
and so on, and so forth. So every single component
already is created here, just with a bare bones,
Dave that displays the text. And what you'll
also notice just to make this tutorial a lot
more entertaining, and move a lot faster
is we've already created all of the styles
as well. So you can see the styles for each of
the components are set up here through CSS. So
all we're going to have to do is just code out
the actual application and use the styles where
appropriate. And we're not actually going to have
to be writing any of the CSS. I'm also keeping a
readme here for your personal portfolio with
all of the relevant links and information such
as the link to a personal website, how to
get started and a lot of other information
that we may be useful for your development
and testing journey. So with all that said,
let's go in and start building
our personal portfolio website.
So let's go ahead and create our very first
component, which is going to be our header
component. Usually, it's easiest to get started
with the simplest component. So we've navigated
here to our header J. S file. And let's go
ahead and we're going to return a container.
And inside of that container, we're going to drop
a div. This is what that div will look like. We'll
turn this into a span. And so this is a div that's
coming from our styled components down here.
You can see here's the styling that's applied
to this div one, and then we're going to have
a link in here the link points back to this
homepage. And then we have this gi CSS check icon,
which is coming from react icons For slash di, and
then we're adding a span that's called portfolio.
If we save this, pay attention to what happens on
the right, we now have this icon that's clickable.
If we click it, it takes us back to our homepage,
because that's where our href is. Next to that
Dave, we're going to add a div to which also,
of course, has its own styling, as you can see
over here, and we're going to add a several items
from that Dave. And the we've got a project a
technologies, and about each one of those having
an href attribute here that doesn't currently
exist. But if we save that, we now see what this
looks like. Of course, in a mobile view, hovering
over all the styling, you can see apply there. And
of course, clicking it should take each one to the
appropriate section. But we don't currently have
the sections enabled. So we'll need to come back
and implement those sections in the future. And
then what we want to do is add one more thing,
we're adding this social Details component,
the component is going to look like this.
Let's save it, this component is going to contain
all of our social details, such as our icons.
And you can see here that it's wrapped in a
div three. And then we have our social icons,
and those social icons have, for example, a
GitHub icon, LinkedIn icon, Twitter, icon,
YouTube, and so on. If you have other
social media that you want to add,
you can simply get any of these icons from react
icons.ai package, if you go to their website,
you'll see all the different types of icons.
And then of course, if you wanted to add others,
you would simply come here and add more depending
on the type of social media that you have.
Next, the other thing that we are doing here is
we are storing all of our social URLs inside of
this constants file. Let me take you there. So
if you go to social URLs, Jas, you can see it's
just an object that contains a link to each one of
our profiles, then we are simply referencing each
of the links here, accordingly. And so now if we
come back to header and scroll down to the bottom,
and below this div, we add our social detail.
So you can see this selection at the bottom
is also going to automatically import for me.
So if I do that, and then I scroll to the top,
you can see the import was pulled in for me
as well. And then as soon as we hit save,
pay attention to what happens on the right hand
side, boom, we got our social icons, you see.
And if we hover over them, you can see in the
bottom left of my browser, it even highlights
the URL, let me make this a bit bigger. So
you can see check it out. So there's that URL,
LinkedIn, Twitter, and YouTube. Wonderful. And in
fact, what I'm actually going to do just quickly,
put YouTube up front, take this,
put it here, save, and there we go.
Let's talk about our testing strategy. For a
moment. Of course, we have a web application that
we're building, and now is a perfect time to think
about a testing strategy for this web application.
And in a web application world, it's really
important to be mobile first, all our
applications, now they have to be responsive, and
they have to support mobile. So that's the very
first thing that we have to check is how does
our web application respond to different mobile
device resolutions. And so a really good way to do
this is to check that as we scale down our browser
to see whether we are finding any issues, and I'm
not seeing any at this point, I'm kind of seeing
some interesting behavior at this resolution where
these three are kind of getting clumped together,
right. And then as we keep scrolling,
I see another issue over here where our
logo is being put on top of this projects header,
which of course is not good to have it's not
professional at all. So that's something that
we're going to need to fix. And then of course,
we can actually get into actual mobile sizes by
right clicking doing inspect clicking on this
mobile device and then you can select your
device from here I'm selecting iPhone 12 Pro,
I'm gonna scale it up to 100% resolution and this
is what it would look like on an iPhone 12 Pro.
looks absolutely fantastic. There are no We should
see here, everything is very readable. And of
course, we don't have anything else. But besides
that, that's what's left. And of course, you can
also check it on a non iPhone device as well. So
that's important. And so what we're going to end
up doing actually is writing automated visual
end to end tests to ensure that our application
looks good on different resolutions. And we can
continue testing through all those resolutions as
we develop our application making sure that there
are no regressions as we hold our application.
The other thing to remember is that we added URLs
here in these icons, right, these are the URLs
that we supplied ourselves. And of course, it's
very possible that these URLs can be fat, fingered
and incorrect. We of course, tested them manually
already to ensure that they are correct. But
there is no reason to think that this can't
accidentally fail in the future. So we want
to ensure that these URLs are correct. And also
that they're matching to the correct icon. Right,
then, of course, we have a navigation for each
one of these items as well that we wrote in our
header. So if we take a look at our header, JS,
right, we put an href attribute for each one of
these here in the future, we'll need to ensure
that they are matching up to the appropriate
section that we're going to code out here.
And then of course, there's this portfolio
section that is supposed to redirect us back to
our homepage, which it has this href attribute.
And of course, that should be checked for as
well. Other than this, I'd say there is no
other real testing needs right now. And
so this is what we're going to work on,
we're going to write automated tests to make all
of this possible. So let's go ahead and do that.
We're going to use two tools that are going to
assist us in our automated testing journey. First,
we're going to use Happo I O, which is a visual
end to end testing tool that allows us to ensure
that our application looks as it should, on
different resolutions. And you can even see
here actually, this is kind of what happens,
it allows you to take snapshots, and then those
snapshots can be compared against baselines. And
then we're gonna run those tests with Cypress i o
Cypress I O is a functional end to end browser
testing tool. And it'll allow us to run our
tests. And then of course, it will allow us to
write our functional end to end tests as well.
So let's go ahead and make all of this happen.
So in order to save time, I've actually already
installed and set up a bunch of information here.
However, if you're doing it on your end, the very
first thing that you're going to want to do is
open up Cypress we do have it already installed,
right when we ran npm install, however, we're
going to want to run MPX, Cypress open. And then
what that's going to do is open up a cypress
UI that looks like this, you're going to have
way more folders and files that come out here.
And it's also going to create a cypress folder
that lives over here, inside of the Cypress folder
is going to have several other folders and several
other files that are important. What we're going
to do is delete whatever folders and files were in
integration. And we're going to create a visual
dot spared dot j s file, that's where we're going
to write our visual tests. We're going to
talk about those in a moment. Then inside of
the plugins, we're going to want to add this code
to be able to use Happo. With our Cypress tests.
Next in the support, we're going to want to import
Happo, Cypress in our commands js file. And with
all of that done, what we can now finally do is
go to Visual spec and write a test. Let me show
you exactly what this test looks like. So here we
have a describe block. And we're saying that our
visual tests will display the homepage correctly.
First, they're going to visit our application and
ensure that our application is in a good state.
And finally, we're simply going to get the body
of our page and take a full page screenshot.
In order to set all of this up and make it run
we need a Happo J S file located in the root of
our folder in the root of our project. So you can
see here it's right next to the package json and
the Cypress JSON. So this Happo J S file has a A
number of important things such as your username
and access key that you can get from your
profile here, if you come here and go to your user
profile, and accountants will be able to get that
information, then we're supplying a project name.
So what we're going to do is update our project
name and call it dev portfolio tutorial. And here
is the most useful part of this configuration
is setting up our targets. So we're basically
saying we're giving the targets a name.
And then we're saying which browser viewport size
do we want to run across, there are multiple other
configurations that we can set. In this case,
we're saying, wait until the last animation has
finished, in which case afterwards, we're going
to take a snapshot, right. So here we're doing
our Chrome 10, ADP, Samsung Galaxy S 10, viewport
size, we're doing iPhone 12, viewport size, and
we are doing the viewport size that caused our
bug that we saw previously, how I determined as
viewport size was coming here. And you can see
as we scroll down and actually if we open up
our developer tools, and get out of this view,
you will see that over here in the upper right
hand side, it shows us the viewport size that we
scroll, so we scroll you can see the viewport size
and then we're going to look for the problematic
one happens that here, there it is, there's a
problematic one. So you see, it's about 656 65.
That's not important. So I put in 650 by 415. And
that's where we catch that bug that we're going to
want to work on. And then the final piece of this
with setting up Cypress is in the Cypress JSON, we
set our base URL to localhost 3000. And that's how
in our visual spec, so if we come to visual spec,
that's how we're able to just visit this forward
slash here because of that. So now with all of
that said, we have a script added here that we're
calling test visual running the following command.
Let's go ahead and run it and see what happens.
And looking down here, we see that our tests
have finished. And let's go take a look at our
Hafele dashboard. So we'll come back here, go to
Happo dashboard. And here we see that we have this
new report called dev portfolio tutorial, which is
exactly our project name, we're going to open up
and we can see our snapshots here, right, you
can see the different resolutions, of course,
beautiful, you can see our bug over here recreated
at this resolution. And then you can see other
resolutions and what our application looks like.
And so in these, everything looks good to me. No
huge issues, of course, except this part here.
And so now we basically set our baselines,
and from this point forward, when we execute these
visual tests, they're going to be compared against
this. And we're going to need to decide
whether we broke something or we did not.
So those are our visual tests, ensuring our
application is looking beautiful across different
browsers and operating systems. What about the
functional aspects of our application? How do
we actually test those? What are we going to do
with all of these links? Let's tackle that next.
What about all of the links that we need to check?
How are we going to do that, in the past, what
I would have done would be to use official end
to end testing tools such as Cypress, selenium,
and I would have gone identified each of these
locators and then clicked on them and then
ensure that they will navigate me to the correct
URL. I learned along the way that that is not the
most optimal approach, there's actually a better
approach to doing that the better approach to
doing that, that I learned along the way would be
to do something like a component test. A component
test, also known as a unit test is something that
we can do to simply check the href attribute of
each one of these elements, right. If we come
here and inspect each one of these locators,
what we see is that each of these has an href
attribute. And so if we know that this URL is
correct, then we know that it's going to take us
to the correct page. Because why wouldn't it the
click ability of a league actually comes from
the a tag. And so if the click ability over
link inside of a tag is not working for you, it's
not going to work for the rest of the internet.
And so clicking it is actually unnecessary. What's
important is just one time doing a check that the
URL actually works. And then after that, all we
simply have to do is check for the href attribute
for its correct value inside of our test. Now, we
can, as I mentioned, do that through a component
test, a component test, what it actually would
have done is, if we came to our social details,
we see that we are passing in a bunch of URLs
through our social URLs object here, right.
And so all of these properties are being set. And
then the social URLs they live here in constants,
and this is just an object pointing to your right.
So we can simply do something like a snapshot test
that ensures that all of these URLs are correct,
that would actually be wonderful, it will take
milliseconds to execute, it would basically
just capture a snapshot of this file. And then
if anything changes about this file, it would let
us know that there's a change. And then it's for
us to decide whether it's a breaking change or
not. The danger with that, and the risk that it
doesn't cover is even though you can have these
URLs, that doesn't mean that they are correctly
hooked up to the correct social icon, right, we
could very easily come here and to do something
like GitHub, because we were copying, we created
one, and then it'll be copied and pasted the rest.
And we forgot to change one of them. I've done
that a number of times in my life, and I'm sure
that you have as well. And so that connection
piece is actually what's missing. And so in this
case, what I think is the best strategy, the
one that requires the least amount of effort,
and has the best coverage is a functional end to
end test. And so a functional end to end test,
of course, as I talked about, was coming here,
checking the href attribute, and then making sure
that that is correct. And so to make that kind
of test possible, what I've written here is this
social details spec J S file, if we take a look
at it together, and actually, we don't even need
either one of these, we're gonna save that. So
what you'll see here is we are visiting our URL
as before. And instead, we are saying that our
social details should have correct social links.
And the way we're getting those attributes is,
we're looking at each one of our locators, you
can see I've used a data Test ID attribute which
makes each one of these properties unique. And so
again, if we come take a look at social details,
J S, we will notice that each one of these icons
had nothing unique about it, except the href
attribute. So prior to adding this data, Test
ID attributes, all of the social icons look like
this. And so how do we reference the correct one,
and ensure that it's hooked up to the correct
URL. And so we do that by adding a data Test
ID attribute and I named each one, right, I said
GitHub, YouTube, LinkedIn, and so on correctly,
matching it to the correct icon. And so with
that, I can now get each one and assert that
each one has a href that matches the correct
value. If we come to our Cypress dashboard,
and we click on social details,
spet, it's going to execute for us.
And all look, it has actually
failed. And if we take a look,
you can see that we're getting a GitHub and
GitHub work successfully. But then if you look
at the YouTube, we see that it failed. And why
did it fail because we were expecting YouTube,
but instead we got GitHub. And that's of
course, because I messed up aka fat fingered,
aka, copied and pasted and correctly, this URL.
And so if we do YouTube, and then we save this,
we come back to our Cypress test, we rerun
it, and everything passes accordingly, right
checking GitHub, YouTube, LinkedIn, and Twitter,
everything is successful. And so ultimately,
the test looks like this. And I'm not going to
write the tests for the other properties such as
these and the even the logo because you already
know how they should behave. And I'm gonna leave
that as an exercise for you to do definitely send
a pull request to the repository and share with
me your solutions and I will let you know if you
got them right or did it. Alright, let's get back
to coding the rest of our application.
And now we're going to go a bit faster.
All right, next, we're going to work on our hero
component, which is going to work our way down.
The hero component is this section of our
application right here. So to make it happen,
the code is relatively simple, I've already pasted
it in, we're going to save it, and then you can
see what comes out of it, you can see all of
the styles that have been imported, they are
being imported from global components, which we've
defined in the appropriate folder, because we're
going to reuse them everywhere. And so here, you
can see we've added a section title, right, that's
where my name comes from, you can definitely feel
free to add yours. And then there's a section text
element here that allows you to define the text.
And then also, you can define this button here, I
put learn more, in fact, maybe we can even change
it to about me, there'll be a better button,
because it's redirecting us to about section
of the page, which doesn't currently exist yet,
but it will, in the future, probably we'll add it
under here under accomplishments, it would be this
section about that we would add in the future.
So let's go ahead and save this, see how that
text updates. And of course, all the styling is
automatically coming from all of these components.
So now we got this version of the application,
let's rerun our tests, right, so we can do
two types of tests now that we have. So we can go
to package dot JSON, right, we can do visual tests
like this. And then we can run Cypress tests,
I'll show you how. So let's run our Cypress test,
you can do MPX, Cypress run, it will actually
run them in the background, and then produce an
output or of course, you can run them through this
UI as well. So it looks like our social details
are passing, which is wonderful, right? We
haven't changed anything about our links. So
that's expected. And then let's do NPM run tests
visual, so that we can run our visual tests and
see what comes out of that. So there we go, our
tests have finished running, let's grab this URL,
and check out what's going on in our Happo
dashboard. So here we can see that this is a
little bit of a different if you now because we're
comparing one check to a pre to a current check,
right. And so we're checking previous state versus
current state. And what we see here is we have
five days, of course, which is great, right, we
can zoom in a bit so that they're easier to see,
this is what our diffs look like, we can put it
in swipe mode. And you can see this is the before.
And then this is the after, right. And of course,
the after is we added an entirely new section. And
this is the before. And so all of that has
shifted down. But in terms of that it looks
good. Of course, there's nothing wrong here.
Of course here in this view, down here,
you can still see we still have this bug that
we're going to fix in the future. And then we have
this section. So that looks good. On Galaxy S 10.
Everything looks good. This is getting a little
bit tight over here. And this is getting cut off,
you may want to take a look at that in the future
to see what's going on and how to fix it. And here
everything looks good as well on iPhone 12 Pro, so
no new bugs introduced in a visual aspect, no
new issues added from a functional aspect. So
of course, we can test the button to ensure
that it navigates us to the correct location.
But we don't have the botany section yet. So we're
gonna do that in the future. One thing we can do,
if we wanted to, we could write a test in, we
can create a new file and call this one hero
dot spec dot j s and we could have a failing
test that would be doing something like this
until we create that feature. That's also
one option. But we're not going to do that
today just because of a lack of time. So
next, let's move on to the project section.
Next, I've gone ahead and implemented the project
section. Let me first start running our visual
tests right, we don't even need to manually test
anymore. We can simply just run our visual tests
and ensure that everything looks good. So I'll
let those run while I talk you through the project
component. It project component is relatively
large however, it's not so difficult that the
main logic here is really on line 34, where we use
projects dot map. And basically that's like a for
each loop where for every single project
that we have stored inside of this array,
and this array looks like this. So you can see
we're providing a title, a description, an image,
the tags, the source code, where to visit the
application, and then an ID. And so you can add
as many projects as you want here, right, you just
keep appending, to the array of whatever you need.
And then this map function will basically use all
of the values that are coming from that array.
So for example, each everything is inside
of a blog card. And then you can see we're
supplying an image that's getting this source,
then we are having a header that's getting the
title. And so the title, of course, is this title,
we are getting card info, which is description,
which of course it's coming from there. And
then the tags, the tags, we also have to do
that for each loop, right to go over each tag,
and then simply add the tags. And then of course,
the external link, and another external link with
the corresponding source and visit attributes.
So that's really that. And then that creates this
beautiful view that you can see here on the right
hand side, of course, totally responsive. If
you of course, want to add your own projects,
you simply need to add all of the images to
this public images folder. And then of course,
update the information for the project. So
you can remove projects, you can add projects,
but leaving these properties in place, you just
obviously changing the values of the projects.
So these tests executed just fine, right? We
can come here and take a look at a moment,
let's run our Cypress tests, what do you think
are the my Cypress says gonna pass or fail? Well,
of course, if they are good Cypress tests, they
are going to pass because we've changed nothing
about our URLs, right, everything is still exactly
as it should be. Let me go back and actually
redo them. And because we we've updated our
application. So having really good tests,
it allows us to update our UI without breaking
the tests. That is really good solid testing.
So and then with all of that said, let's
take a look at the Happo comparison.
So we'll see a new view that we haven't seen
before. So here is those here are those defs.
So again, the original, and the new one. And of
course, here it says we need to review it. So
we're going to review it, and here are the five
diffs, 10, ADP, everything looks great. Chrome
650, of course, still has the bug because we
haven't fixed it. But in least everything else.
Let's take a look here, everything looks
wonderful. So everything is being rendered
correctly, everything is looking great.
There's nothing weird visually going on,
and everything looks good. And of course, then we
can probably expect a similar thing here. And so
of course, at this point, let's just go ahead and
accept all of these. And now they're going to be
used as a baseline for our future iterations, even
though we have a few more sections to implement.
Alright, so I've gone ahead and implemented the
rest of the application in the interest of time
so that we can talk more about testing and of
course, do the most fun part, which is deployed
to production so that we can proudly display
it to the entire world. So I've implemented a
technologies section over here, as you can see is
just a bunch of static text here that's written
that describes all of this information.
If we navigate to the technology section,
you can see that all everything is pretty much
hard coded here in this component. Right. So
in terms of risks, what are the risks with this
section that we need to tackle with new tests?
Absolutely not actually, visual tests take
care of all of the risks they are for us.
That's the beauty of visual tests. We've
written them once. And now we can continuously
use them to check on our application.
Speaking of which, let's run them now.
While we continue to talk through our application,
so then we get to our personal accomplishments.
Our personal accomplishments also show A
bunch of data here, if we take a look at the
accomplishments, we will see that there is
this data that's hard coded here, could be
very useful to actually move it to our constants
folder and just put it in there. But you will see
how we iterate using a mapping method over all of
our data. And that's exactly how we display it.
So what are the risks that we need to check
for here, for example, in this case, should we
write another functional end to end test that will
validate that this part of our UI correctly reads
the data in the back end? No, in this case, we
don't need to do that. Because this data is simply
displayed here. If there's anything weird, that
comes out of this, like, for example, let's say we
put one zero last here, and the amount of projects
here, that will show up in our visual snapshot.
And we'll be able to see the differences. And
so that's the nice part about the static data is
being reflected here. And we can capture it again,
with a visual end to end test that already exists,
protecting us from all of these risks. And then
the footer down here is also very simple. So let's
take a look at the footer from the source code
perspective. So the footer is very simple, you
will actually see that we are reusing our social
Details component that we've not only written
before, but we also have tested. That's why we put
it into an individual component so that we can use
it down here. And so of course, if we've already
written and tested it to retest this down here
as well, no, we don't, it's the same exact source
code that we've written and tested before. And so
we're good here. The only other risk here is this
link that will do and mail to that could be double
checked, we could ensure that this has the correct
value. And what would be the best way to do that,
we could simply do a components test to ensure
this has the correct href value. And that would be
good enough, we could do a functional end to end
test with Cypress. But I don't think that in this
case is necessary. Now I do have one interesting
question for you. In terms of a testing challenge,
how do we ensure that these projects links
are correct here? So right in the View app,
if we take a look at the projects, right, they're
iterating over two arrays, one of which gets us
the source and the visit from our projects file?
Here, here are all of our projects, right? How
do we ensure that this URL and this URL, and so
on and so forth, are correct, even as we modify
these projects. So one initial thought that
I might have is to do a functional end to end
tests like we've done with Cyprus, right? For
example, if we come to our social details spec,
we checked all of our URLs in this
manner, right, in this case, making sure
that the UI is correctly connected to our
file and reading from it correctly. However,
what's going to happen when we add
a new project. So now we need to add
another test. And then the other challenge of
that is now not only do we need to add a new test,
we also need to then start adding unique data test
attributes for every single button that we add. I
mean, I guess that doesn't necessarily have to be
too much work, we could make it somehow dynamic.
But that seems like a lot of extra effort for
testing, just the fact of testing these components
here. So instead, what we can actually do is use
a components test is specifically a snapshot of
our component to ensure the validity of
these components here. And let me show you
exactly what I mean. And for that, we are going to
use just Jess which is a unit testing library that
also allows us to do snapshot tests with the code.
So let's take a look at exactly what I mean. So
I've configured here a snapshot test. You
can see in our constants folder, I've added a
projects dot test dot j s The reason it's called
projects dot test because it's testing this
projects file that contains all of the relevant
resources. And this projects test file is saying
that we're going to have a test. And it's checking
that the project details are correct. And we're
importing our projects object. And then we're
expecting our projects object to match an inline
snapshot. So when we initially use this method, in
fact, I can even show you here, what just is going
to do is generate a snapshot of this project. So
of course, we can access different properties, and
so on and so forth. But we really want the entire
object, and I'll show you what that looks like.
So if we come here, and of course, I already
added a script, that's called NPM, run test jest.
It's going to execute this test. And what you also
see here is, is just filled in this entire object
into our code. So it's written here, everything
about our objects, such as a description, the ID,
the URL to the image. But even better, it's
captured our links to ensure that they are
correct. So similar as with visual testing, all
we have to do at this point is ensure that all of
this is correct. One time manually. And now from
this point forward, we can use the snapshot as an
acceptance criteria for any future changes. And
what may a future change look like? For example,
let's say that for whatever reason, I was in
here, and I accidentally messed up this value. And
I said, or I even Yeah, let's do this first.
And so then if we rerun NPM, run test chest,
we're going to get a failure. And the failure is
going to tell us, hey, you expected us to match
your inline snapshot. But look at the difference
I found. I expected this, but I got this.
And so of course, that's a bug and we can
reject it. So I'm just going to go back here
and save that and rerunning it, of course, it's
going to pass it beautiful. But then of course,
even if you wanted to add a totally new section,
give us give it a new ID, and then rerun just
we're going to get an expected failure, because
of course, it doesn't match our snapshot. And
just as gonna tell us, hey, I see this totally
new object is this. Okay, so of course, you
manually validate that everything works here one
time, and then afterwards, we now have this test
to ensure that nothing breaks in the future.
And with that said, we're able to successfully
check everything, all of the data about this
section, especially the URLs, which are hidden,
of course, everything that's visible, can be
captured by our visual test. But the URLs are
hidden, but they can be checked by our snapshot
test. And so with all of that said, that captures
this risk, and then we never revisited our
Happo dashboard. Let's take a look at those
tests. Let's take a look at our new snapshots.
We can see our brand new snapshots. This is
what they look like now, right? Much larger.
Everything here looks good. Everything looks
wonderful to me here. So of course I'm going to
accept and now any future changes, we can go in,
review them and make sure that nothing is broken.
Thank you so much for joining me here today.
I've been Nikolai Adva lockin, founder of ultimate
qa.com where I create training on coding, testing
and deploying web applications. It's been a true
pleasure hanging out with you today. And if you
have any comments on what you want to learn next
time, please go ahead and comment below. And if
you want to learn more for me, you can follow me
on my YouTube channel. Alright, see you next time.